as application developers we need to  know about data gravity  data tends to pull applications to it as  if it has gravity  data does this because it's harder and  slower to move a database than to move  business logic  this means two things to developers in  my opinion  first when you architect a new  application carefully consider what  database to pick you will most likely  stay on it for a long time  but we can worry less about where the  business logic will run just put it in  containers so it's easy to move it start  with cloud run which is serverless so  you can launch quickly stay on cloud run  or move to kubernetes later on if you  have to  second backup restore analytics  pipelines and ml pipelines are slow and  difficult  automate them cloudrun and cloud  functions are great for automation as  they are serverless and scale up as your  data grows  remember that data gravity and plan  accordingly